grandpa thank you so much because even
beyond wherever he is just still
thinking through you I'll take it
michael buble exceeded all expectations
on the latest episode of celebrity I owe
you with the help of the property
brothers the singer paid an emotional
tribute to his late grandfather by
fulfilling a very important wish to
provide his caretaker with a place to
live with her family
I hired Manette the nurse to come and
live with them and by the end that was
his best one when I was talking to you
and you said right away you know who you
want to give back to take your grandpa's
dying wish to give a space to Manette
yeah when that doesn't keep any of the
money that you made she's got a lot of
family in the Philippines and she takes
that money and she sends it all back
she's really a special beautiful woman
my grandpa would be so happy this was
his dream
I think my grandpa would be thrilled
knowing that we could maybe lessen the
burden a little bit and allowing him the
net to continue helping her family
without it being so hard on her I guess
I am part of the family so of course
having this opportunity to give back to
Manette was huge for the singer and it
also meant reuniting with Jew and
Jonathan Scott who grew up in the same
neighborhood as Michael but all this
excitement may have led Michael to push
himself a little further than his body
could handle during demolition day so
the boys asked me if I could get in
there smash a little walls get a little
dirty yep the gloves on you at the
glasses I know I look like I'm ready for
it but inside I'm just tender yeah the
singer later revealed the sledgehammer
got the best of them that day telling
Entertainment Tonight I don't know what
I did it was so bad but I went and got
an MRI after he added it turns out I'm
just out of shape and I'm a wimp and the
sledgehammer was too much for me but I
got in there I refused to not be in
there with them now after the complete
overhaul it was time to reveal the
masterpiece to Manette who was in the
Philippines visiting family while the
renovation took place Michael actually
had to tell her he was shooting a
documentary about himself and his
grandfather to get her on camera as she
never liked being the center of
attention
documentary-style
we're just recounting grandpa Michael
taking through it you guys just be you
she would ask me details and I would say
to her listen it's a documentary I'm not
allowed to have details
she is like she's gonna flip be lying if
I didn't say I was really anxious
nervous excited and all of the change
they change the windows but ed thinks
Michael and his sisters have done some
updates to the house since grandpa
passed so she has no idea that the
renovations are for her I hope that she
loves it as much as I do because when I
walked in honestly genuinely I was
absolutely blown away there's little
changes I know that but I think he'd be
more happy that the house stays in the
family do you want to go in yes
reminisce one to school would have meant
so much to my grandfather to know this
house would be filled with love I can
only imagine what its gonna mean to her
oh my god and then everyone got
emotional when revealing the once
crammed home to Manette which was now
renovated into a wide-open modern Oasis
she could call her own my grandfather
his greatest wish was not just that I
kept this house in the family but it was
that this would be your home because he
loved you so much and so there is no
documentary this is all for you
Oh God
I know do you think what do you think I
think would you like to meet this if I
was it helped welcome huh ah he's making
cry you don't like it
of course I love it was also really
great to know a home so meaningful to
Michael's grandfather is staying in
their family so what did you think of
Michael's edition of celebrity IOU let
us know in the comments below